le 7 mars on fait quoi non ça c'est pas
le sujet le 7 mars toute la France sera
bloqué contre la réforme des retraites
et parce que cette réforme nous concerne
nous aussi les jeunes on s'attend à ce
que tous les lycées et toutes les
universités soient bloquées contre la
réforme des retraites c'est pourquoi on
lance le hashtag blocus challenge postez
vos plus belles photos de blocus de
lycée et d'université parmi ces photos
on en tirera une sorte et l'équipe de
bloqueurs sera invité à visiter
l'Assemblée nationale avec nous donc on
se retrouve le mardi 7 mars pour mettre
le pays à l'arrêt et participer au
blocus challenge on se retrouve mardi
pour faire reculer
alors pierre Alicia merci d'être là
conseiller régional d'Île-de-France
merci bonsoir
pourquoi la Région a décidé de porter
plainte après ça parce que la région est
responsable des lycées d'abord bien sûr
du bâti notamment et que là on a
clairement un appel d'un député de la
République à venir bloquer un lycée
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que c'est un
blocus de lycée en général c'est des
violences et des dégradations des
dégradations de bâtiment on a vu qu'en
Île-de-France l'ensemble des lycées qui
ont été bloqués ces dernières années ont
été dégradés et ça a causé plusieurs
milliers d'euros plusieurs centaines de
milliers d'euros de de
dégâts qui sont pris en charge par la
Région et donc par le contribuable donc
un député de la République appelle comme
ça dans un concours un peu stupide à une
surenchère de la violence et des
dégradations c'est irresponsable donc il
est normal que
la région est Valérie Pécresse porte
plainte contre ces déclarations il est
anormal que les autres présidents de
région président et présidente de région
ne l'est pas fait il est anormal que le
ministre de l'éducation nationale ne
l'est pas fait non plus
et donc on est dans une situation
aujourd'hui où d'ailleurs il est pas
normalement non plus que la présidente
de l'Assemblée nationale n'est pas réagi
autrement que par un simple tweet en
disant
l'Assemblée nationale n'est pas un prix
de concours sur les réseaux sociaux
de concours la politique n'est pas un
challenge Tik Tok vous devriez les
servir vous leur faites du mal respectez
votre fonction respecter votre
institution respecter les Français et
donc voilà donc et donc qu'est-ce qu'on
fait après ça là le bureau de
l'Assemblée nationale a déjà sanctionné
des députés qui ont eu des comportements
irresponsables il me semble que là on
est en regardant totalement
moi je suis choqué quand le pire des
réseaux rencontre le pire de la
politique ça donne Louis Boyard en fait
c'est n'importe quoi il y a aucune
conviction il fait gagner des visites à
l'Assemblée nationale comme s'il faisait
gagner des crémiers hydratantes à ses
abonnés c'est vraiment n'importe quoi et
je pense qu'il doit être sanctionné il
faut arrêter au bout d'un moment et le
pire c'est qu'il encourage à la violence
et à l'escalade de la violence parce
récompense le meilleur blocus ça veut
dire quoi plus vous allez être violent
plus vous allez être récompensé passer
on marche sur la tête il a il a pété les
plombs là c'est un élu quand même moi ce
qui me choque c'est que un député
appelle à commettre un délit il faut
savoir que un blocage c'est un délit
c'est entrave la lip circulation des
personnes les lycéens n'ont pas le droit
de manifester dans un lycée par le droit
de bloquer un lycée et lui il appelle à
ça donc il appelle à la violence je
trouve ça complètement irresponsable
pour moi il a pété les plombs alors je
ne parle même pas du prix qui est de
visiter l'Assemblée visiter l'Assemblée
tout le monde peut y aller il suffit de
demander une visite à son député on y va
donc l'assemblée n'est pas à mettre
comme ça aux enchères d'un d'un d'un
d'une annonce de Louis Boyard c'est
délirant son comportement effectivement
vous avez raison de porter plainte et il
faut que l'assemblée comme elle a
sanctionné d'autres députés le
sanctionne d'un retrait de son indemnité
parlementaire Valérie il se comporte non
pas comme un député mais comme un leader
d'un syndicat étudiant donc il s'est
trompé de fonction et s'il voulait être
l'identique à étudiant il fallait qu'il
reste leader d'un syndicat étudiant
effectivement mes camarades ont raison
c'est que bah on peut aller l'assemblée
comme on veut et qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire le plus beau blocus là où ma raison
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'il
faut amener la photo de du lycée le plus
en feu ou le lycée le plus explosé le
plus enfin pardon je ne comprends pas
alors il y a Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui
avait réagi qui avait dit bravo Louis
Boyard
tous les perroquets du régime sur joue
l'indignation ils font de la pub à ton
idée ils ont oublié les cloneries de
Macron avec les youtubeurs voilà donc
voilà le YouTube McFly et Carlito à
l'Élysée
4 Nans donc il a plu
Raymond bah oui là je réagis aux propos
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon ça n'a rien à voir
entre invité deux gars parce qu'il a
fait une promesse dans les jardins de
l'Élysée entre dire foutez le bordel
dans vos lycées casser les biens publics
et après je vous ferai visiter
l'Assemblée et il y aura même des sodas
à volonté ça n'a rien à voir moi je me
demande en plus je pensais qu'ils
allaient justement avec Mélenchon
racheter le Garrido tout à Alexis
Corbière je pensais qu'il y a un moment
donné qu'ils vont le remettre dans le
droit chemin et dire arrête parce que tu
nous fais plus de qu'autre chose en fait
moi j'ai l'impression
je suis surpris qu'il encourage parce
que en fait c'est plus vos amis non ils
ne sont pas mes amis juste
l'Assemblée nationale c'est pas voilà
c'est pas un terrain de jeu où on invite
à Paris c'est des champions
noirs de chevaux la merde comme comme
Louis Boyard l'a fait sur ce plateau je
viens pour [__] la merde mais après je
veux qu'on me donne raison mais il s'est
incitation à la violence c'est un
supportable de la part d'un député quoi
il faudrait le virer ce mec-là ça peut
être aussi contre-productif parce que
peut-être que les lycéens et les
étudiants vont pas avoir envie d'être
récupérés
que quand les CRS ils vont gazer les
étudiants ou quand vous allez [__] le
feu dans votre lycée que vous allez
prendre des coups lui il sera pas là lui
voilà c'est toujours pareil il y a les
mecs qui appellent à la révolution sont
jamais là
parce que
mentalités
que ça coûte je ne sais combien à la
région par exemple c'est nous Bayard qui
va payer le français
juste un député ne devrait pas dire ça
pierre non mais au-delà de dire ça ou
pas en fait c'est c'est illégal vous
avez raison ça tombe ces propos là tombe
sur le coup de la loi appelé à
manifester appeler à faire grève c'est
tout à fait légal appeler à bloquer un
établissement c'est effectivement une
entrave à la libre circulation c'est
aussi une entrave à au droit à
l'éducation donc tout cela tombe sous le
coup de la loi oui Boyard c'est c'est un
député Pyroman c'est à dire que c'est
même pas un pompier pyromane le pompier
pureman il est en mesure d'éteindre le
feu l'incendie qu'il a lui-même allumé
Boyard ne sera ne sera né aujourd'hui
même ce soir pas en mesure d'éteindre
cette mèche qu'il a qu'il a allumé et
qui va essaimer dans des centaines voire
des milliers de petits cerveaux malades
au premier rang desquels celui de son
grand leader Maxime moi Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et et qui vont s'adonner comme
ça à une surenchère des dégradations
surenchères de la violence le tout
stimuler comme ça sur les réseaux
sociaux et sur et sur sur Tik Tok il
faut quand même rappeler que un député
c'est fait pourquoi c'est fait pour
faire la loi pour rédiger la loi alors
j'ai un petit doute sur les capacités
intellectuelles de Monsieur Boyard pour
rédiger un texte de loi mais à minima
c'est de faire respecter la loi faire
respecter la loi pas inciter à la violer
Benjamin et Daniel voulait réduire ou
pas là alors Benjamin qui est pas
d'accord c'est mal fait effectivement la
violence mais pour une fois il a un
positionnement pour une fois il dit
voilà il y a pas les jeunes on a pas les
étudiants on n'a pas les lycéens on en a
besoin politiquement donc c'est c'est un
message qui lance donc en fait la
manifester je crois que le message était
pas pour une fois il n'était pas idiot
après
une conviction je trouvais ça pour une
famille un peu après la fin est nul pour
moi c'est pire moi je pense qu'il veut
pas bloquer il veut que ça dégénère
bordel il veut que les filles qui tapent
les étudiants et qui dit que vous avez
vu la police on vous le dit en fait
vraiment c'est c'est un mec révolution
en fait moi je pense que c'est un danger
public donc vraiment c'est je trouve que
c'est irresponsable que c'est pathétique
et que Pécresse a été très courageuse de
de porter plainte moi je vous propose
c'est quand même des mineurs donc il
appelle vraiment il les envoie au feu ça
scandaleux et Louis Boyard c'était plein
qu'on dégradé la fonction de députés ben
je le rassure il a pas besoin de
personne il a besoin de personne pour la
dégrader de la dégrade très bien
lui-même donc franchement c'est pas
digne d'un député quoi vraiment
dérapages c'est quand tu dis ici c'est
quand il fait un clip de rap éclaté avec
un kebab c'est quand il fait une vidéo
il incite à [__] la merde il ne veut
que ça il veut juste des abonnés sur
Instagram fait tik toker mec fait pas de
la politique au bout d'un moment ils
s'enfuit il n'a aucun souci
exactement
c'est un petit peu de patience vous
inquiétez pas ça franchement on a pas
beaucoup attendre non mais en tout cas
bravo à Valérie Pécresse d'avoir
vraiment
les jeunes c'est ce qui fait les
manifestations des jeunes c'est la
terreur des gouvernements dans tout
mouvement social ils ont besoin alors
les jeunes peuvent manifester mais
appeler un blocage c'est à dire appeler
potentiellement la police a répondu
d'ailleurs la police a dit ben si vous
bloquez nous on sera là parce qu'ils
sont obligés ils vont avoir des ordres
ils sont obligés appeler qu'un député
appelle à une confrontation parce que
c'est ce qu'il fait entre des jeunes qui
vont bloquer des policiers qui vont
vouloir débloquer c'est complètement fou
parce que c'est un appel à la violence
or imaginez qu'un jeune soit blessé dans
un mouvement ça responsabilité ou pire
sa responsabilité sera écrasante donc
c'est délirant est-ce qu'on peut
destituer un député Pierre lisseur
malheureusement non malheureusement non
on l'a vu avec les différents
divers pardon
merci Jean-Marie
qui ont émaillé la vie de l'Assemblée
nationale non aujourd'hui les les
députés sont là
grâce aux voix au suffrage du peuple et
c'est leur seul légitimité donc s'il
doit ainsi s'ils sont amenés à
démissionner c'est parce que eux l'ont
choisi on l'a vu avec 4 nains on l'a vu
avec pas mal d'autres députés ils sont
obligés de démissionner eux-mêmes et
j'imagine que vu le train de vie d'un
député et et et les compétences
professionnelles de Monsieur Boyard je
doute qui démissionne de ce de ce
justement là